Jean-Marc bonjour alors 24 heures après
les annonces du Premier ministre les
Français font leurs comptes et surtout
les chefs d'entreprise est-ce que tout
ce qui a été annoncé à et de nature à
bloquer l'activité comme beaucoup le
craignais d'abord les festivités du
nouvel an
écouter d'abord bonjour bonjour Samantha
les chefs d'entreprise est très inquiet
jusqu'à hier parce qu'il était un peu
comme tout le monde depuis une semaine
le gouvernement
tu travailles comment Condé Condé agenda
Condé emploi du temps et qui ont des
difficultés sans doute pour faire garder
leurs enfants.
cela peut avoir des effets à plus long
terme
oui alors ça sans aucun doute ça va
avoir un effet
des maintenant l'année 2022 qui
s'annonçait très bonne va sans doute
être handicapé par l'arrivée de se voir
au micro
il va falloir je crois que la semaine
prochaine
ils vont quand même tournée très au
ralenti on peut aussi avoir des vagues
de hausse de prix dans l'énergie on peut
retrouver des bacs de tri dans l'énergie
et puis le travail contenu des métiers
en tension va sans doute augmenter tout
va dépendre en fait de la gravité de
cette nouvelle vague de le micro le
gouvernement
il a pris le sur l'hypothèse que la
vaccination nous protéger des cas grave
donc pour soulager l'hôpital il paraît
aussi sur la vaccination total avec ce
fameux passe vaccinal qui va être votée
au parlement la semaine prochaine il
Paris enfin que le vaccin bah
alors est-ce que cette nouvelle étape
Elven la situation politique
alors forcément ça va
dans quel sens parce que là
depuis le début depuis presque 2 ans
maintenant Emmanuel Macron a fait
beaucoup d'erreur au départ
aujourd'hui
liberté je crois que la gestion de la
pandémie peut profiter au président à
condition que les choses se calme et pas
de catastrophes nous approchons j'aurais
pas été 200000 contamination par jour
maintenant donc si ces contamination ne
débouche pas sur des cas extrêmement
grave
ça va passer si on se retrouve à
l'hôpital avec des réanimation saturer
là ça risque de casser mais en face
personne m'a véritablement réussi à
prendre le lead la gauche a disparu les
écolos sont plutôt éclater la droite se
partage entre Valérie Pécresse Marine Le
Pen
économique